we're told that maya and doug are
finalists in a crafting competition
for the final round each of them spin a
wheel to determine
what star material must be in their
craft
maya and doug both want to get silk as
their star material
maya will spin first followed by doug
what is the probability that neither
contestant gets
silk pause this video and think through
this on your own before we work through
this together
all right so first let's think about
what they're asking they want to figure
out the probability
that neither gets silk so i'm going to
write this in shorthand so i'm going to
use
mns for maya no
silk and
we are also thinking about doug not
being able to
pick silk so maya no silk and doug
no silk so we know that this could be
viewed as the probability
that maya doesn't get silk she after all
does get to spin this wheel first and
then we can multiply that
by the probability that doug
doesn't get silk dug no silk given
that maya did not get silk maya
no silk now it's important to think
about whether
doug's probability is independent or
dependent
on whether maya got silk or not so let's
remember
maya will spin first but it's not like
if she picks
silk that somehow silk is taken out of
the running in fact no matter what she
picks it's not taken out of the running
doug will then spin it again and so
these are really two
independent events and so the
probability that doug
doesn't get silk given that maya doesn't
get silk this is going to be the same
thing as the probability that just
doug doesn't get silk it doesn't matter
what happens
to maya and so what are each of these
well this is all going to be equal to
the probability that mai does not get
silk
there's six pieces or six options of
this wheel right over here
five of them entail her not getting silk
on her spin
so five over six and then similarly when
doug
goes to spin this wheel there are six
possibilities five of them
are showing that he does not get sick
silk dug no silk
so times five six which is of course
going to be equal to 25
36 and we're done